all right so Michael Michael friend cz
good let me do a brief intro and you'll
maybe help me with some of the details
so that's the best story that sums up
everything is back in the 80s Fortune
magazine did a cover story on the 50
biggest most money-making mob bosses
right and you were a number 18 at the
time correct and your father was also a
mobster he watch and you had a an
illustrious career in the mob and I
guess we wish we start with your
childhood I guess yeah I guess you know
I mean obviously I grew up under that
influence my dad was a very prominent
figure during the 1960's especially it's
kind of like the John Gotti of his day
oh there yeah it was a tremendous amount
of publicity you know a lot of media
attention major major target of law
enforcement it was almost like you know
I used to think why did they pick him
out of all the people out around at that
point time but he really was the kind of
media star at that point in time yeah
well you know he revealed that to me a
little bit later on after my mother
passed away because I asked him I said
dad you know why you why did they you
know I have this concentration
fascination with you at the time long
story short he said he was dating
Marilyn Monroe and Bobby Kennedy found
out about it and from that point on
Kennedy made my father his target and I
ordered Hoover to go after him and you
know it makes sense I'll be out my dad
sometimes you know he embellishes things
a little bit but that story makes sense
and he knows that he was secret very
well he does yes yeah so as a kid
growing up with a father like like your
dad what how was your childhood
different than then most people
was a lot different I mean you know back
then law enforcement tactics against
organized crime were very different than
today I mean today everything's very
covert undercover informants high-tech
surveillance back then when a guy was
under investigation they wanted you to
know about it and my dad was under
investigation maybe seven or eight
different agencies FBI IRS queen
detective Brooklyn da they were all
there and they would have a car parked
around my house 24 hours a day seven
days a week because he was on the
constant surveillance so you know I was
one of seven kids and every time we went
anywhere we had a parade of law
enforcement vehicles following God's
signatures the way it was and that was
for several years and so you know I mean
look my dad was my hero he was a great
father I loved him so I grew up actually
hating law enforcement and I had many
little scuffles with them as a kid you
know and and so that was kind of the
environment I was in and then your plans
as you grow up were we're not to follow
your dad's footsteps they were you were
actually free yeah I was a pre-med
student that was I was an athlete I had
no desire to be become a member of his
life mainly because my dad didn't
discuss it with me he didn't talk to me
about it he did encourage me you know
you know one thing I really respected
about him many things obviously but he
never brought what was going on in the
outside world into our house in the
house we were a family so he never
talked about it he needed acknowledge
who he was you know none of that so to
me I'm playing ball you know if you said
to me as a kid you know who would I like
to emulate what what I'd like to be
I wanted to play centerfield for the New
York Yankees you know Mickey Mantle was
kind of my guy but so no I didn't I
didn't aspire to be in that life but I
was gonna be a doctor my dad wanted me
to go to medical school so that's what I
was pursuing and you know until he got
in some trouble and things changed for
me what was your direction well my dad
was indicted several times in the early
60s three serious charges in the state
of New York and he went to trial beat
them all you know
but then he was indicted in federal
court from masterminding a nationwide
string of bank robbery
convicted sentenced to 50 years in
perspective 50 which was kind of a death
sentence for him at that point it was 50
years old he went in so I figured he'd
never come out of prison alive so you
know at that time Joe Colombo he kind of
took me under his wing he had just
started the italian-american civil
rights League of Joe Colombo's and was
the boss of our family correct and we
were close you know he kind of took me
under his wing my dad and him obviously
would close my dad was his underboss so
you know I I got highly influenced
people out of my dad's friends say Mike
what are you doing going to school if
you don't help your dad out he's gonna
die in prison so you know I lost
interest in school then I was picketing
the FBI every day with Columbo in that
league so I was meeting a lot of guys I
was getting you know all the courage
that maybe the league would help my dad
so it was kind of a direction change for
me I went to see him in Leavenworth and
we sat down I said dad I'm not going to
school if I don't help you out you're
gonna die in here and you know we kind
of went back and forth because he didn't
want that for me but he knew my mind was
made up I was pretty headstrong as a kid
and he said okay but if you're gonna be
on the street I want you under Street
the right way and his mind I wish to
become a member of his life so was at
that point that he proposed me from
membership into that life and so what's
the first step you you started doing
small yeah well he sends word downtown
you known he'd said to me just do
whatever you told he knew I had it in me
so otherwise he wouldn't have done that
and so I went about two weeks after that
visit a captain and a family took me to
see the boss now many people don't know
some people do that Joe Colombo was
assassinated and it was an attempt on
his life he eventually died from the
wounds a new boss took over his name was
Tom DiBella Tom's passed on now and I
sat with him and he said I got a message
from your father he said you want to
become a member of our life is that true
I said yes he said well here's the deal
from now on 24 hours a day seven days a
week you're all called to serve this
family the Colombo family and to show me
how serious that was he said that means
if your mother is sick and dying and
you're at her bedside we call you to
service you leave your mother
you come and serve us from now on we're
number one in your life before anything
and everything when and if we feel you
deserve this privilege this honor to
become a member will let you know so I
was 21 close to 22 years old I was in
like a recruit period where either doing
anything and everything I was told to do
to prove myself worthy well listen you
know it could have been something very
menial there's a lot of discipline in
that life a lot of authority you know
you had a meeting it you know 7 o'clock
you weren't there at 6:30 you were late
could never be late in that life drive
the boss to a meeting you know sit in
the car for five hours god forbid you
leave you go get a newspaper but a
restaurant becomes out you're not there
you're in trouble I know I did that once
paying the price well you know a lot of
stuff like that I mean you had a show
that you could take authority and that
you would discipline that's not it so
forth yeah and then you know look I'm
always as honest as I can be about that
you know the life is very violent and if
you part of that life you're part of the
violence and there's no escape anybody
tells you differently they're either not
being honest with you or they weren't a
made member of that life about two years
18 months two years something like that
I was in this recruit period you're
great everybody seems that way yeah it
was Halloween night 1975 when I was
called into a room with five other
gentlemen all recruits and the
interesting thing at that point was that
I they had an expression just before
that period where the books were closed
in that life meaning they weren't
bringing in any new members formally and
in the early 70s they opened up the
books and I was inducted with guys that
were waiting 2025 years they all
recruits that long yeah so I was kind of
a mix in there that night but we all
took a note that night became sworn made
members of the Colombo family how many
there was six of us they said yeah and
you were how old I was 24 24
and so you know I heard a story of those
six gentlemen that were inducted that
night what how many they were still
around well I do the six of us
I'm the only one alive and the other
five were all they all died and from
what I understand they were all murdered
so dangerous treacherous tough life yeah
first was a very solemn ceremony
you know dimly lit room late at night
they wanted you to understand the you
know the seriousness of what you were
getting involved in and we walked into a
room individually the boss were seated
at the head of like a horseshoe
configuration on the boss console area
to his left and riding all the captain's
along sided and we had about 15 in our
family at that point walk down the aisle
stood in front of the boss held on my
hand takes a knife cuts my finger some
blood drops on the floor this is a blood
oath I cupped in my hands you took a
picture of a saint Catholic altar cloth
put it on my hands with it aflame didn't
hurt it burnt quickly was merely
symbolic and he said tonight Michael
Franzese you are born again into a new
life until the Cosa Nostra this thing of
ours violate what you know about this
life betray your brothers and you will
die and burn in hell like this Saint is
burning in your hands and he said do you
accept yes I do
and then what changed you know you you
you kind of find your way in that life
and you ureter how could I put it you
know you separate yourself in being in
one category the other even though we're
all capable of doing what we need to do
and what we're told to do but some of us
were earners I would call us and some of
us weren't you know and and
unfortunately the greater percentage of
us were not earners but in our family at
that time you know we had 115 made guys
guys that actually took deal with a lot
more associates but guys it actually
took the oath how did 115 I think 20 of
us were real earners you know the other
95 guys there you know getting by doing
some of the heavy work
you know who's who's got a gambling
issue who's getting a union job you know
we tried to take care of them but you
know just the way it goes like anything
else you gotta separate yourself in that
life and were the first like business
endeavors that you were well you know I
was fortunate in that I understood early
on how to use that life to benefit me in
business but you know and I had a head
for business so to say it was very
aggressive on the street brought some
new things into the family but I really
started out you know my dad had me
working in an auto body shop when he was
home you know just helping some guys so
I started out in the car business that
turned into me owning two dealerships at
that time I built it up I had used car a
lot at a leasing company I had body shop
so I had a pretty big business that I
kind of grew in a short period of time
and then you know along with that life
you saw that people come your way and
they they offer you deals and you know
you you accept do you reject depending
upon the quality of what's going on and
before you know it I had several
different interests on my own nightclubs
and restaurants and again a leasing
company I ended up with a production
company in California so I had a bunch
of different things going on and you
know was able to turn things into
successful operations that's great and
then eventually you got you hooked into
something that was we see it was
actually the gas business and you know
very long story short I got approached
by someone had a small wholesale
operation selling gas on Long Island and
there was two guys from another family
trying to extort him shake him down and
he came to me for help I was kind of the
guy on Long Island and so I helped him
out and together we devised a scheme to
defraud the government out of tax on
every gallon of gasoline and that grew
from a very small operation to at its
height after eight years I ran it for
about
years we had over 350 stations that we
the owned or operated we had 18
wholesale companies that were licensed
to collect the tax on every gallon of
gasoline and we built that up to selling
half a billion gallons of gas a month
and we were taken down 20 30 40 cents a
gallon depending upon the deal so you
know it's very lucrative we brought in
you know at times 7 8 10 million dollars
a week it was that big yeah it was a big
operation
I brought the Russians in from Brighton
Beach and it was you know is described
as the most lucrative operation since
the days of prohibition and I saw it
that way also and then a 2-star when
you're making that kind of money money
is power in that life and you know I got
the attention of some of the other
families and so I made you know
relationships which is important in that
life to have allies and the other
families so tried to spread some of the
wealth around and you know make people
happy and money buys loyalty in that
regard so oh yeah it started to make a
name for myself stories I heard you
share once was helped get this off the
ground and he came into the box one day
yeah Benny Benny was a butcher and he
was one of my guys trusted guy big you
know ominous looking guy big scar across
the top of his head a butcher and that's
why I put him with this guy Larry that
came to me with this whole proposal for
gas and after two weeks in the operation
he comes to my house with it he used to
bring me meet every Saturday and now
he's carrying a big box and I said well
what are we having a party I don't know
I could do it all this meat brings it in
a kitchen puts it on the table and says
it ain't meat boss he said it's the
first weeks taking a gas station opens
it up three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars smell I guess when he smelled up
the whole kitchen but I didn't care at
that point but we grew that 320 and to
like I said close to ten million dollars
a week Wow and so at some point I'm sure
your boss at the time was Persico first
of all my purse guy and he like
what was his reaction to this well you
know when I knew what I had you know you
gotta be very careful in that life you
know if too many people get involved
everything goes up in smoke it happens
all the time so when I went to him I
told him I said junior called him junior
I said look I'm gonna show you more
money than you ever saw in your life and
he looked at me right away it's not
drugs we don't do drugs I said it's not
drugs you know I hate drugs personally I
hate drugs added in my family I said
it's gas I said you're not gonna
understand it I said but I got this
operation under control nobody else is
gonna be at risk it's me my guys my crew
but I'll make you wealthy but here's the
deal every time we have a sit-down
excuse me an argument with another
family I gotta win don't play politics
let's not spread this around because as
soon as we do it'll get out of control
and we'll blow it and he said show me
and I did and I never lost an argument I
mean he made him wealthy and he repaid
me by being loyal in that regard close
to eight years from 78 you know right
through 85 when I went to prison well
I'd moment jet plane I had a Lear 25 a I
had a Bell Helicopter you know I built
8000 square foot house in Long Island I
had a house and Florida and house in
Marina del Rey California you know so I
mean I had all those little perks but
you know honestly the the plane and
helicopter really business I mean I use
them you know quite extensively but well
you know I looked I enjoyed the the
fruits of I'm sure you're meeting all
kinds of dignitaries and celebrities and
you're running in a circle that's very
very different yeah I mean I had you
know associations with people that had
you know good celebrity connection so
got involved with that to a great degree
and you know life was good of course on
the other side I'm fighting the
government every day of my life yeah so
at some point during the during this
heyday of the gas business that you
then somebody got suspicious that you
were kind of keeping more of the money
than you should
should have done for yourself and you
know me yeah you know when you're making
that kind of money you know people
they're watching you you know it's kind
of a double-edged sword and you know I
was a younger guy I've been appointed a
captain you know they made me a
confident person go did and I had a big
crew at all the Russians that were very
loyal to me making a tremendous amount
of money yeah I was in my 20s late 20s
and you know there was a publication I
think it was Newsday I'm not positive I
don't remember now but I wrote a story
that I was becoming powerful enough to
break away from the Colombo's and start
my own family it was fiction I'd no
truth to it whatsoever but that was one
reporters take on it so you know that
gets into people's heads you know when
people thought to Wanda I think Persico
got a little bit you know suspicious of
that so started to send some people
around to talk to my Russian connections
and so on and so forth so you know how
to watch myself at that point and though
I had no interest in you know taking
over families matter of fact I'll be
honest with you I hated going down to
the social clubs and being stuck in
Brooklyn when I can get on my plane and
go to Florida California and you know
enjoy the good life that's what I was
into so you know and your captain in
that family it's a lot of work because
you got guys unto you that are
constantly getting in trouble constantly
needing you you got to sit down you got
to be arguing all the time I mean you
know I mean I enjoyed the life and I was
as much a part of it as anybody but I
also like the good life so you know I
had things that people used to say to me
I used to go out to California a lot
here and people used to tell me how is
it out there and I didn't want anybody
to follow me so I said oh it's horrible
those people that's terrible you know
you know I didn't want to go out there
so I don't want anybody come out
meanwhile I loved it right
same with Florida you know but you know
so I had to watch myself and you know I
was on my garden I knew it so you know I
was careful yeah and then
finally come to an end my now that I
come to an end of the well I became a
major target of enforcement I mean I
wish to die yeah no I mean I had I
totaled it up by it's seven indictments
you know that's that's almost a record
you know I mean in that life you usually
get one or two and you're gone you know
but I had seven and two federal
racketeering case Giuliani indicted me
on a big case in 84 I was probably the
first major mob guy he indicted under
the RICO statute and I was lead
defendant I had 15 co-defendants and I
was on trial for several months if I
lose that case I'm gone you know I would
have been away for 50 hundred years
that's you know I'm watching these guys
going to trial getting convicted and
getting a hundred years 200 years I said
man I'm the youngest at all of these
guys they're gonna give me 500 years if
I lose this case so you know I I
prepared day and night for the Giuliani
case in all total probably about two and
a half million dollars you know between
all the cases I you know it took care of
some of my co-defendants and
investigators you know and then forget
the hours that I lost just you know
preparing but yeah I spent a lot of
money but it was worth it I mean I won
the case I was acquitted so I've got my
freedom yeah at least at that point yeah
I beat him five times
yeah I went to trial three times fourth
time was dismissed and Giuliani was
acquitted I got I got a pretty good
string now you're also involved in
sports gambling as well well you know if
you're in that life you're into gambling
in some way no I didn't have that habit
and I used to gamble a little bit on
sports or I played the numbers every day
5:27 my birthday one a few times but
we had bookmakers that answer to me and
they would gambling I mean athletes were
gambling with them you know all the time
all the major sports teams like a lot of
the college kids you know just happening
yeah not Michael Jordan was apparently
some mess with well look I wish you was
on the street I mean everybody knew
Michael was I I only use were degenerate
in terms of his gambling your added
terms of him personally but yeah he was
he was on kids still today I mean
everybody knows that he's not shy about
it yeah but he was gambling with
bookmakers you know the way we're aware
of it yeah and so what happens after you
actually did yeah what happened after I
beat the Giuliani case the East that was
in the Southern District of New York and
then the Eastern District from New York
was preparing this whole gasoline tax
RICO case on me it was kind of a laundry
list of things they indicted me for but
you know gasoline was one of them and
the guy that introduced me Larry I Rizzo
to the business and then we created the
scheme together
he turned informant algae so he was
their principal witness against me
however he testified against me in the
Giuliani case and we destroyed him on
the stand destroyed him so the
government was leery about him coming in
on the second case which gave me some
leverage when I finally negotiated a
plea there so please got you how many
years I took a plea eventually to a
10-year prison sentence I had 15 million
dollars in forfeitures and restitution
and I gave up the plane to helicopter a
whole bit
and went off to do my time but you got
to understand at that time when I got 10
years I negotiated it for months people
were saying hey it's the deal of the
century yeah they would tell me don't
even take his shoes off you'll be home
before you know it really you know but
that's how bad it was back then I was
very fortunate no I find it very
interesting that you have navigated your
your time with the mob and your your
life today with I think it's I think
it's yeah there's many people have many
different types of intelligence but
there's a wisdom in knowing how to how
to play a certain situation or a certain
person you're interacting with to come
out on top to come out unscathed and
compared to if we got that list of
fortune the 50 mob bosses the only one
is still alive
we're all still not in prison well no no
no I know 48 of them are dead yeah I
don't know about the 49 that heard he's
in his 70s you might have passed away I
know he was doing a long prison stretch
I don't know where he is
so yeah I mean I'm the guy that's
walking around free I mean it's you know
look I always say that list was kind of
silly the ns4 on tax returns you know
they'd make a list like that sold a lot
of magazines but you know it's not silly
even to myself as to think that over the
last 33 years I survived all of these
guys I mean it's it uh it makes me
realize how fortunate and blessed I am
you know to know that but you know this
whole thing you know it was all a
negotiation life is a negotiation and
when it came to this next case that they
were going to they were after me on I
knew I had a shot when we defeated their
major witness in the Giuliani case they
were devastated and so I told my lawyer
look I can't keep fighting these people
eventually they're gonna win and when
they do win I'm going away forever I
said I got to try to cut my losses so in
taking that plea what I really was
concerned about look I wasn't afraid to
do the jail time I was visiting my
father or my whole life I knew at some
point I do
prison time I had 17 or 18 arrests up to
that point but uh I said I gotta cut my
losses and what was more important to me
than anything else was getting immunity
from any other crimes so I knew if I
wrapped everything up in that plea deal
I did a few you know years inside I come
out and have a clean slate and they gave
me immunity for everything except murder
you know at that time unless I became a
cooperating witness then they would have
given me immunity for murder but I
wasn't interested in that so that was
the only thing I to be concerned about
and I wasn't really concerned about it
and so it was really a negotiation to
preserve the rest of my life and get
these people off my back that's what it
was all about did you have an eye on
getting away from I did you know a
couple of things came into question for
me but I saw that that life was in a lot
of trouble
I mean Giuliani I have to give him
credit or blame whatever way you look at
it you know for really utilizing the the
the RICO Act and up until that point you
know guys weren't becoming his
informants as much as they were but
nobody wanted to face that kind of time
and I saw the life starting to fall
apart because of that the government had
too many weapons they had the RICO Act
they had the bail Reform Act at the
sentencing Reform Act guys were turning
snitch left and right yeah better
surveillance you know and we didn't keep
up with the times and so I said this
life is in trouble
you're gonna stay here and I'm a young
guy for me to be arrogant enough to
think that over the course of my
lifetime these guys wouldn't catch me in
something and put me away forever would
have been arrogant on my part yeah ten
years was you know I did eight on the
ten but it was you know it was a bluster
you look at everyone else around you
absolutely and didn't and didn't have to
put anybody in prison didn't go into
witness protection program none of that
which I wasn't interested in so you know
so everybody said it's unheard of it's
never been done before I mean I don't do
research on it but I don't know of
anybody else has been that fortunate
does the reaction to other Mouse's at
the time and even you're kind of leaving
well they didn't know it I mean I I
didn't make an announcement at some
point you well I tell you what happened
when I went into prison I was in there
for a bit and the associate warden had
Terminal Island that's where I was
incarcerated tells me you know like
magazines doing this huge story on you
they had done a huge story on my dad
several years earlier was that actually
the biggest story ever as far as I know
in Life Magazine about my dad it was
like 29 pages with a fifth photos and
everything else right so he said they're
doing kind of an anniversary edition on
you and he said the reporter said if you
speak to him it'll be a better story so
me always trying to negotiate stuff I
said alright maybe I get the government
off my back a little bit you know
whatever get out of here get some peace
so I sit down with them and I said you
know I tell them typical mob stuff there
is no mob you know I know what you're
talking about
I married this young girl she's from
California I moved out I like the sunny
weather I gave him all that stuff right
and I was it I think a couple of weeks
later the warden calls me back to the
office and he says frenzies do you have
a death wish
that's what are you talking about you
know he shows me the article there was a
big double picture a big article and
across the top quitting the Mafia and
there's a big picture of me and I'm in
jail with several other mob guys this
guy had me doing everything but testify
nobody leaves no no you know no and then
right after that you know I get a visit
from the government FBI tells me hey
words all over the street from your
informant from our informants you're a
dead man anyway
you know cooperate with us we'll put you
in a program and so this thing started
like accidentally you know I didn't say
what's testified against anybody but
then they put word out on the street
that I was going to testify they put my
name on the witness list of of other
trials that were going up you know so
people were seeing that on the discovery
it was like a wave that I couldn't stop
but I did have no intention to going
back so messages came through to me
what's up I said look I'm not gonna hurt
anybody but I'm done well that
infuriated the wrong people so including
my father so I mean I had a lot of
trouble
yes you know I'd like to clarify that I
mean obviously the contract on my life /
should go very upset when he heard this
and I'm done
plus they thought I was going to testify
so you know I was told straight out my
father went along with the contract and
you know and knowing my dad I believed
it you know I don't think my dad would
have pulled the trigger on me but you
let it go your wisdom to navigate
negative things like that your own
father
kind of standing against you and yet
using it finding some way to turn that
into something positive
yeah and your relationship if your dad
was still alive
yes just out of prison recently my dad
still life is 102 years old he was
released at the age of a hundred yeah
there's the oldest in maintenance system
I'm sure your relationship with him is
great it's it's you know it's good you
know it's we kind of see things a little
bit differently at this point you know
but the relationship is good I love my
dad he loves me you know there's a lot
of talk out there and all this stuff
that I never did anything to her of my
dad I only tried to help him my whole
life I'm the guy that got him out of
prison you know and all these times but
you know people talk and they like to
say certain things and whatever but my
dad nightclothes and you know I love him
he loves me he was a big influence in
your who you are my dad was a tremendous
influence on him he taught me you know
all the right things when I was a kid
growing up I believe I still carry that
with me you know he he helped me
navigate through that life taught me to
be a good listener you know to be
careful before I speak out of turn and
things that you need to know in that
life that are very important because you
guys had shut off the mouth and wanted
to be tough guys there all done you
don't keep somebody that around when you
got to worry about somebody doing so you
let them go get rid of them and that's
what happened so that happened many
times in that life
what got some of the personalities I'm
sure you you came across quite a few
real characters yeah yeah you know I was
friendly with John you know
we weren't best friends and it was
different cruise and all that I had my
run-ins with him you know with what
Gotti socially he was great you know I
used to meet him in some clubs or you
know by chance or on purpose we have
drink and have fun he was great he was
always had to be like the center of
attention he was the magnet everybody
because the way he dressed the way he
carried himself but but I was a lot of
fun business very tough very very tough
because you know he had the attitude I'm
John Gotti and nobody's gonna beat me
and so when you in a deal with him
whether it be purposely or by chance you
had to now to navigate your way through
so he thinks he got what he wants but
actually you get what you want yeah and
I appreciated John John doesn't know it
but he taught me that just am I having
to deal with him you know and getting my
way at the end yeah well you know you
get the credit I'll take the money yes
that way is it who else mouth figures
were interesting well you know I enjoyed
Tony Salerno Fat Tony Salerno he's a
boss of the Genovese family he was a
character you know right out of central
casting but a good guy I liked him I had
a couple of you know meetings with him
and enjoyed him very much and the gas
business especially you know he knew I
was making money I had he asked me for a
couple of things and I was able to help
him Paul Castellano I met under not
great circumstances my first real run-in
with a guy was him and didn't you know
he wasn't one of my favorite guys let's
put it that way
you know Persico obviously I know I mean
I knew a lot of guys I mean I got around
you know I knew the chin you know fairly
well chin Gigante and you know he really
was the most powerful guy on the street
at that point in time he really was I
mean you know he did his thing you know
walking up and down Houston Street in
the bathrobe and all of that but very
interesting he didn't care who you were
he didn't care you could be the boss of
another fan he didn't care if you didn't
want to meet you talk to you he wouldn't
and the fact that he met with me you
know
few occasions and and treated me that
way which was nice you know he respected
my father a lot too my father was away
but he respected himself you know so I
met you know I met the good guys the top
guys at the time and I met a lot of the
other guys you know because you're in a
gas business everybody wanted a piece of
it
everybody so I was constantly sitting
down and keeping people away and arguing
and it was it was a lot of work but it
was profitable so you did the work right
oh no not a lot but you know day of my
arraignment he told me if he convicted
me he's gonna give me a hundred years
double what my father got and I said hey
bring it on Rudy beat you already four
times let's go for round five and
unfortunately I beat him but you know
you know Rudy sits him did some nice
things about me when it was out on the
street that you know I was transforming
my life and I was given not going back
and everybody was saying
Francie's is full of it on law
enforcement side he'll never give this
up he's too much a part of it it's
another scam he's pulling and Giuliani
said you know what Michael is a fairly
intelligent guy and he knows this life
is in trouble and I think he might be
sincere on what he's saying he made that
comment so it was nice well look he like
I said you want to give him the credit
of the blame but you know he did a lot
as far as hurting my former life and I
will say this I think he was a terrific
mayor I tell you a story you know I I
had been I did my five years I was out
there teen mods violated my parole so
they picked me up and they're bringing
me back to New York I was out in
California because I had to go in front
of the judge you know and the marshals
were transporting me and I said look
what time we got to be at court he said
like two o'clock was early in the
morning we got off the plane I said well
do me a favor I haven't been here for a
while let's drive around Manhattan I
want to see what's going on I said that
I want Dunkin Donuts having that in
awhile - so the marshals were good guys
so we started driving around we go to
Manhattan and I was shocked to see Times
Square yeah I grew up Times Square was
you know a pit it was horrible don't you
know and Julia Annie totally transformed
it so you know he did a lot of good
things as mayor and of course 9/11 he
gets you know both sides but I think he
did a good job so give him credit
so one of the qualities that a person
needs to exist but it seems like very
often is the case where for deceit and
treachery coming in a picture you know
it's it's a very treacherous life and
the reason I say that because look I
spent a lot of time there over 20 years
I mean you know I seen guys die for the
wrong reasons jealousy comes into effect
there's a lot of politics money's
everything money and power is everything
in that life and you got to know how to
really navigate both and if you're
making money and you have power you got
to know you got to be careful you know
you don't want to offend the wrong
people I mean look the gaudy castellanos
thing was a perfect example and our
family you know a little bit Corina
you know he went out against Purse ago
we had a big war at that time so you got
to be very careful yeah you got to be
careful you know just to do the right
thing with the right people or to be on
your guard all the time and you know
again I saw a lot of people die for the
wrong reason you know one of the horrors
in that life you make a mistake
your best friend walks you went to a
room you don't walk out again and
unfortunately I've witnessed that and
you know I had somebody very close to me
that I believe was killed for the wrong
reasons more to give me a message than
to anything else and that was was tough
for me to get over I mean really was
because things look you know I'm not
throwing bouquets at myself and I'm no
angel by any means but you know I saw
two types of guys in that life there
were guys there that I would call them
stone killers they enjoyed it you know
hey give me the contract I'm ready to go
I do now and they did it did their job
you know for me when I was asked or
ordered to do something it made me
uncomfortable
don't get me wrong I never let anybody
see that and you know I did what I had
to do and did it and you know in my case
it was kind of like stepping outside of
myself doing what I had to do and
getting right back because I wasn't
gonna let anybody talk about me and I
was gonna make sure I did what I was
told to do follow the orders but I think
there really was those two type of guys
those two type of personalities and I'll
tell you this the guys that were ready
to kill they don't last they don't last
because people say I'm not gonna worry
about this guy he's too quick with the
trigger you know one thing that I
learned if you're a captain in that
family you know and I want to clear this
up too
murder was taken very seriously in that
life we weren't random killers we didn't
do drive-by shootings we weren't allowed
to do that stuff we didn't do it any
murder in that life had to be sanctioned
by the boss that was it had to be
sanctioned by the boss there was
discussion about it some people afford
some people were against it and then a
ruling was made and you know I always
thought about this I said look this life
is like a wheel it turns around you know
one day if I'm sitting there you know
giving a vote deciding the fate of
somebody I want to be hesitant I'm not
going to be the one to say right away
let's do this so let's do that or or you
know put a death warrant on this guy
because it might be me sitting at one
day there might I mean might be me that
they're deciding upon one day and I want
to be known to be the guy that said
let's really discuss this let's wait
let's see and you know I think in the
end that served me well because I had an
experience where I was brought into a
room one night I didn't know if I was
going to walk out and an experience that
prepared me for walking away later on
because honestly I learned through that
experience that I could face death
they were suspicious that you were up
there yeah I mean I was called into a
room under some very bad circumstances
and the way the setup was you know look
making a lot of money in the gas
business you know and word was getting
out and like I said my boss was was
going after fun and some people seen if
I was turning in enough money and all
this kind of stuff I'm turning in
millions you know story came out that I
was making billions you know my attitude
would have been well so what he's taking
all the risk he's doing this he's making
me wealthy what do I care but it's not
like that what everybody so you know I
think you know when I look at it they
wanted to put a scare into me maybe
maybe it was serious more than I thought
afterwards I don't know but you know oh
yeah let me tell you something it was
about a 30 yard walk from the car that I
get out of to the basement of apartment
or room it was a private house but we
had to go into the basement down the
steps and it was late at night was a
summer night I can tell you this the way
it lined up I said I'm dead I'm not
walking out of here when I walk down
that path as I think about it now
I I can hear the crickets chirping and I
can almost smell the the night air the
flowers my senses got so acute at that
point and you know I've said this before
him people said to me why didn't you cut
and run and I said you know I don't know
I mean it was just robotic I said hey if
this is it this is it but I will tell
you this you know my heart was beating
out of my chest and when that door
opened I don't know how I didn't just
cave in because I thought you know I
know the setup guys stand up boom you're
done it's over with and but it taught me
later on that I could face death so when
I did walk away and I knew that I'd have
that trouble I said hey you know what
they're not gonna walk me into a room
they're gonna have to come and get me
and I knew what to do to change my
lifestyle around so I didn't make it
easy for anybody because there was you
know a couple of attempts I mean I know
that for a fact
after you yeah oh yeah there was there
was a crew that's was sent out to
California
and the FBI intercepted it and they
actually came to my house and they said
if you don't leave you're not gonna
you're gonna be dead by Sunday
that's the deal because fortunately at
that time that a lot of informants on
the street and my wife was a wreck they
told her to and I got mad at them and
they said well we wanted to make sure
that you left you know whether they
liked it or not if you have a death
threat on you they're obligated to come
and tell you so we had to pick up and
move and leave for a couple of days and
until I knew it was over with so I had a
couple of you know calls like that back
to your house your well yeah well you
know you don't create patterns in your
life don't walk your dog at the same
time you know go to the same restaurant
you know hang out in places where you
know other guys hang out want to be a
hero so you know I was very disciplined
because I knew I had to be but you know
it was tough you know and like I said a
lot of treachery in that life that you
got to watch and you know look I'm as
honest as I can be about the life and
I've told people this that life is an
evil lifestyle just like the gang life
you know it's evil now I'm not calling
the guys evil I was one of them I just
happened to be very fortunate very
blessed but the lifestyle is evil
because I don't know any family of any
member of that life and this includes
gangbangers that I went to prison with
that hasn't been totally devastated I
mean devastated including my own and not
my wife and kids my mother father
brother sisters the family is destroyed
I don't even know how I came out of
there would have you know at least
somewhat sane people question that so
any lifestyle that does that to families
has to be evil and that's the bottom
line
I mean you got to stay away from that's
what I told these gangbangers you guys
are out of your mind and we're these
kind of thoughts in your head what
helped you kind of change your ways and
decide to leave you know leaving that
life was one of the if not the most
difficult decision I ever made because
look I took the old very seriously on my
father's son I love my dad
I would go to sleep at night leaving me
into life and wake up going back in I
mean I was so torn it was it was it was
so difficult emotionally for me because
I didn't want to be known as a guy that
betrayed an oath whether it was right or
wrong because look I had a very
idealistic view of that life when I came
in I was going oh I'm gonna be part of
something my father's part of you know
this Brotherhood among men it was
exhilarating and I took it extremely
seriously
so leaving that life was was very very
difficult it really was I mean sometimes
you know even even at a moment I mean I
feel it today every wata be out of your
mind to me to be in that life you're
going to jail you're going down one way
the other at one point in time
especially it was too late for me I
became too high-profile once you got
that bullseye on your back you got that
target they'll never let you go they got
all the time all the money all the
resources so they're gonna get you when
they do get you it's over that's it
treachery free kids yeah I got a you
know a wife to them 34 years here we
live out in Southern Cal I got seven
great kids you know three from my first
marriage but they all love each other
which is great look I live a good
lifestyle I mean you know I'm speaking
all over the world having a a positive
impact on people being a source of
encouragement and hope which is
extremely gratifying you know I really
learned in my life it really is better
to give than receive you get a better
feeling out of it you know and what else
can you give me I've gotten everything
just about my life but it motivates me
keeps me going very fortunate I am a
person of faith you know and look and my
faith has played a major role it's
without God in my life I don't think I'd
be sitting here now I mean I know that
for a fact so you know and things I've
had my challenges and my struggles don't
get me wrong and you know I didn't get a
lobotomy when I became a person of faith
I still have tendencies where I could
jump back in and mob life for a second
but I try not to and I got the right
people around me to keep
be accountable so you know it's all
working out
excellent what a great great story
thank you Michael thank you very much
for sharing it appreciate it thank you
thank you